MADE IN PITTSBURGH AND PLENTY OF
THEM.
>> Steve: DEVILS
SHOT SAVED BY HALAK.
WHORE TOUGH TO CONTAIN.
EVERYBODY TOUCHAT THE SAME
TIME.
LUKE IS ON THE WAY AT
TWO-ON-ONE, MERCER WITH HIM.
HUGHES SHOOTS, HE
DO
DOESN'T GET MUCH ON THAT.
A HIGH
ZACHA HAD TO TAKE THAT PLAYMAKE
TRAVEL ABOUT TEN, 12 MILES TO
NEWARK.
IT WASN'T TAXING AED BY HUGHES,
SHARANGOVICH, SCORES!G.
ABLE TO BAT THAT PUCK AWAY WITH
THE BACK OF HIS STICK.
TH LITTLE BIT
OF A BREAK ON A CREASE AREA.
WALL.
AND THE DEVILS, TO WAY,NUCKS.
THE REDIRECT, THEY SCORE.
THE SHOT OFF THE STICK OF OF
BESSER.
AND THE CANUCKS KEEP THE PUCK
ALIVE.
THERE'S THE BLAST FRO NET.
AND THE DEVILS ANSWER RIGHT
BACK.
>> Ken: THAT'S HUGE
HUSTLES, OUTRACAC.
DON'T DO ANYTHING TOO CUTE.
JUST FIRE IT TOWARD THE NET.
I'M NOT SURE W WZACHA.
SCORE!
BUZZING.
THE WORK BY ZACHA AND ABOUT BEI
BETTER DEFENSIVELY,  BETWEEN THE
DEFENSIVIVE OTHERS REMAIN ON TH.
NOW A STEAL BY SHARANGOVICH.GHT.
RECOGNIZES IT'S A FORWARDG A PE.
HE WAS BEHIND HIM.
>> Steve: HERE'S A CHANCE
THEY DROP IT BACK.
QUINN SECONDS
LEFT.
SO
>> Steve: THE ISLANDERS' DRAFT
TATAR AFTER HE DID A GOO
AS DAWS PLAYS IT ACROSS, WE'LL
WATCH
HAMILTON FROM BOQVIST AND